foreign
one of the things I would say things
pushbacks that I always get
specifically on social media I'll kind
of like make it that umbrella
um of anything we teach anything any
money content that I put out there the
number one pushback that I always get is
when I tell couples to share bank
accounts
so when I talk about combining your
money being one all this I mean eight
people come out of the woodwork mad at
me and then I saw an Instagram reel of a
pretty well-known person We're not gonna
give him a shout out but he was saying
no you should have separate accounts and
then he got all this backlash probably
from Ramsay people I was like no it's
the worst advice you need one account so
there's all this conflicting advice out
there perspectives all of it but
I mean I stand pretty pretty strong on
this I remember us I think we were out
at days we were having a conversation I
remember thinking
so you'll share a bed
you will share genetics and make humans
make kids
you'll share
legal transactions like buying a house
and buying cars everything yeah but not
that seems like a strange place to draw
the line and I get it feels like it's
this pseudo safety right it's like
people like me who are kind of mini
Preppers who like I got my my I got mine
over here my beans stored up in the
basement like that's gonna protect you
right
um
I honestly it's one of the few things
that I I outside of an abusive
relationship if you've had an abusive
past where somebody like I get wanting
to protect yours I get that
that's one of the few things Rachel I've
tried to wrap my head around and I just
can't I don't understand the the the the
hate you get for telling people
you gotta split up your bank I mean you
got to share your banking yeah because I
think one of the biggest motivators is
fear of divorce what right what if he
leaves what if you want to leave and you
don't you can't have any money I mean
it's a lot of that rhetoric that's part
of this there's that and then there's
this like independent
oh I have my own thing it feels good to
make my own money be responsible for
myself there's like an independent side
as well don't get married on both of
those because getting married is a
decision to not be independent anymore
but to create a new entity together
right uh two becomes one like to create
a new path forward in the world that you
were once all by yourself and now we are
forever joined as a gang totally so talk
about that because I think there's one
element to me that you know people like
well we fight all the time when we share
accounts but when we've separated them
we don't fight anymore because we don't
have to talk about it I'm like that's
like saying well yeah you're a voice
you're literally avoiding the biggest
fight
unless I drink a whole lot and then I
just feel better right yeah it's like
yes well that works I guess until it
doesn't that avoidance I'm like yeah
yeah on the surface sure but then you're
sweeping under the real issues of why
you don't want to share your accounts
and then do you think that habits of oh
we don't talk about it we're gonna avoid
it that that seeps into other areas of
marriage not just money does it become a
hat does it become a I think and I think
it's I think it reveals
I am hanging on to either a tiny little
corner of this person I used to be I am
I've got a fantasy that I'm gonna oh I'm
it's gonna be me but we're just gonna be
married now I I think it is not going
all in and I think it I think that's
just one of those things that reveals it
because if somebody says
um I refuse to share a bed with the
person I just married people would be
like you're weird right I mean that just
doesn't make any sense right
um unless they snore a lot and then God
bless you go to another room yeah
but but like there's these other things
I'm not ever putting my spouse on my
partner that's just weird right or my
house no that's right
but this is the one that we're all like
yeah you go right so I get it but here's
the deal it's pseudo autonomy it's not
real yeah because if you get divorced
the the judge is going to split it up
right and it it's just not real yes
unless again
you are there's abuse or addiction or
something you know what I mean like are
you trying to protect yourself yes yes
and you have to create an off-ramp yep
somebody it's kind of like the last call
somebody else has already breached
broken that relationship right and now
you're trying to stay alive that's a
different thing but if you're going all
in to be married
you've got to go all in yeah and then
I'm like I literally was thinking about
this I was like okay so before kids I
guess tactically
it could be somewhat you like okay yeah
you get these bills that but then you
get the kids I mean I just know for us
like I'm not gonna start in soccer and I
have to buy uniforms I'd be like will
you buy them yeah like who who does the
Zoo membership you know what I'm saying
like how do you I don't understand
tactically how you live out life so on a
tactical sense you guys it's so much
easier to function out of one account on
a very tactical high-level surface
reason it's like yeah we're all working
out of the same pot so we can figure out
okay where's our money going we're
getting out of debt we're putting this
money here it's easy there and then what
ends up happening out of that is like
yeah we end up talking about life we end
up actually having to trust each other
we end up having to talk we end up
having to fight like that's all good
have hard disagreements yes because
you're all iron sharpens iron towards a
common Mission a common school because
two jobs
or we avoid fighting or the con like
people people that avoid conflict
specifically marriage but in life
talk to like talk to America about this
because you're just you're good at
communicating this but like you just
lose the depth and the richness of
marriage if you just are in constant
avoidance right and it's going to come
out sideways one way or the other but
but actually like having conflict and
fighting and I'm not saying being
hurtful to your spouse and name call
right like but being able to have
conflict healthy conflict is really
important for a marriage beneath
conflict is this idea that I have enough
value that I can say out loud what I
need and what I want and when I say out
loud what I need and what I want and I'm
married or I'm dating somebody seriously
I've just entered into a risky
proposition because the other person who
I love and I've dedicated my life to
might say no yep and so instead of
heading into those murky Waters
we just hedge our bets and I ask people
to read my mind I ask my wife to just
imagine what I want for dinner instead
of saying hey I can't do another pasta
dish because I've got gas so like I need
we need to do something else right and
so I just don't say anything and then I
get home and my wife has been working
her butt off all day for this amazing
pasta dish and my first thought is right
I've just created conflict because I
didn't express my needs out loud because
I was scared of rejection the rejection
right of the other side of this thing so
I just hedge it and so everyone has to
know this
a conflict delayed is conflict Amplified
anytime I choose to squash what I feel
squash what I need squash what is true
it will show up and it will have been
lit on fire and so you can deal with it
in the moment in the present
or you can avoid it and it will show up
in the weirdest places and by the way if
you pay the light bill and I pay the
water bill and you pay the rent but I
pay the car insurance
just wait till somebody takes too long
of a shower
and it's like hey I pay that bill and
now you've created division in your
house being married is hard enough right
right don't create extra barriers
towards connection right yes and on the
financial side I'm like
to win long term and to truly have this
level of peace that we talk a lot about
on the show
and to say okay yeah we have goals for
our marriage and for our life we want
this and that and that running on two
separate tracks it's really hard to get
there to go in the same it's much easier
to be like we're gonna jump on the same
road and go down the same path and think
about what we don't do think about like
a business you have a marketing
department you have a sales department
and you have the building maintenance
department
all two of these apartments don't look
at the other one and say hey you got the
phone bill we'll get to this bill we'll
get to this bill there's a common pot
that pays the bills right everybody puts
into this thing we do it in our business
but we we just think we're magic and the
rules don't apply at home they just do
yes I want couples who decide hey we're
going all in go all in yep go all in and
if it you get burned somebody hurts you
somebody cheats on you whatever and it
doesn't work
know that you went all in not that you
hedged and didn't study for the exam and
you got a D on it you're like well I
didn't study yeah study
risk study
stunt getting a d because you probably
won't you probably won't it's a scary
conversation for those of you that may
have separate accounts and you're
listening to this and you're thinking
gosh I really do I want to be try it for
90 days try it for 90 days and risk the
hard conversations you're all gonna have
to have in order to join those accounts
it will be worth it in the long run or
it will reveal that your relationship
has bigger issues than you all are
willing to talk about
show we'll be right back